our top story this hour France rocked by
rioting for a fourth night police
arrested more than 1300 people during
fiery protests Nationwide more than 70
officers were injured French president
Emmanuel macron has called for calm
following days of unrest after a police
killed police officer killed a teenager
during a traffic stop near Paris Elaine
Cobb is in the French capital
these Paris streets bear the scars of
last night's clashes as the French
government tries to control the
situation Nationwide and curfews have
been imposed on some communities
the main Flashpoint is now Marseille
France's second largest city on the
Mediterranean Coast is at the other end
of the country from the scene of the
deadly police shooting protesters hurled
stones at police cars there and masked
youths torched trash cans as police used
tear gas to try to clear the crowds
spurred on by a challenge on social
media crowds of youths attacked a
shopping mall smashing windows and
losing clothing stores
the interior Minister ordered in
reinforcements to back up local law
enforcement in the city
riots II in Lyon in the East where SWAT
teams were deployed and in towns and
cities across the country as arrests
indicate some of the protesters were as
young as 13.
the policeman who fired the Fatal shot
that killed 17 year old Niall has been
placed under formal investigation for
murder he has apologized to the family
but a statement released Yesterday by
two police unions which called the
protesters Savage hordes and Vermin has
compounded the perception that French
police are racist
the funeral for the victim is being held
today in the Paris suburb where the
shooting took place the family has asked
for a private ceremony and the local
mayor has appealed for calm for CBS
Saturday morning Elaine Cobb Paris